starting to wonder a little bit about
what I'm gonna call the Kyle Shanahan
effect both in Atlanta and in San
Francisco watching the Niners tear apart
the Vikings D on Sunday night a guy that
watches all of this stuff for a living
Andy binoy he's a staff writer for
Sports Illustrated NFL analyst and the
mmm QB he also has the ten things
mm QB podcast that I had the pleasure of
going on one time you can check him out
on Twitter at Andy underscore Hanoi Andy
I want to start there with the Atlanta
Falcons and the Niners how significant
do you think what I am coining the Kyle
Shanahan effect will be on those two
teams yeah I am fascinated to see that
because Shanahan last year's an
offensive designer was the best in the
league and it wasn't even close and
we're in really Ross what he did so well
is he uses his running backs and his
bass players his running backs his tight
ends he puts them in passing situations
in passing formations and unusual
passing formations and it forces the
defense to be very predictable because
when you have running backs and tight
ends on the field but defense is going
to be in a simpler coverage because they
have to account for a possibility of a
running play so you get a simpler
coverage and then you make it more
predictable from there and then Shanahan
is extremely good at spacing and angles
and understanding how the timing of
routes when you sync them together how
that can out out leverage a defense so
and those are things you can do with any
players you don't need Julio Jones to do
that it certainly helps and we'll find
out how much it helps now that Shanahan
is doing this in San Francisco but there
was a lot of subtlety and nuance in this
regard to Atlanta's offense last year
and and now that guy's gone and Steve
Sarkisian is gonna be calling the plays
and he'll want to do some of his own
wrinkles and we'll see how that goes
it'll be fun to watch the best offensive
coordinator in football he had the most
talented offense most likely now he's
got maybe the least talented one and
we're gonna see where both of those
teams fall and I am
no idea how it's gonna shake out yeah
it'd mean it'd look pretty good the
other night with Hoyer and Pierre garçon
and Marquis Goodwin was flying out there
it'll be like you said very intrigued to
see how that ends up playing out
speaking of intriguing you had your
Superbowl predictions but you also
talked about a defense that you feel
like Annie I don't want to put words in
your mouth but that the Texans have
invented is that is that correct that's
that's relatively new in order to try to
slow down the Patriots is that is that a
fair statement um probably you know and
you probably encountered this to Ross
any time you ask a coach he how did you
think that concept up they always say oh
I didn't think that up some coach I knew
20 years ago knew a coach ten years ago
who and he came up with it I mean
everything seems to start from way back
somehow but what what the Texans bid
last year there's certainly
revolutionising it as a mainstream
concept now they line up five and this
is passing situations they line up five
defensive linemen or deef defenders it
could be linebackers as well they line
them up just right across the front it's
very simple and what they do is it makes
five on five five blockers for five
defenders and the beauty of it is
there's two beauties of it one is it
creates especially against the team like
New England where Tom Brady likes to put
everybody he can out in a rout it makes
one on one blocking scenarios offensive
linemen are forced to block one on one
and then two is the defense can decide
who has to block who by just who were
where they land the guys up so that's
what Houston does and it forces one on
one but with Brady and where the
concepts really evolving and by the way
Denver did this in the 2015 championship
game when they when they beat New
England Denver had not shown this more
than six times all season they did this
15 times in that game you just line up
five but you only rush three of them and
then you drop to back and what that does
it still gives you the one-on-one
blocking because the linemen have to
block the guy who's initially in front
of them the ball is designed to get out
quickly because those laymen were in
one-on-one blocking scenarios but now
there are eight defenders back in
coverage so the ball can't get out
quickly and that's how you get JJ Watt
for example going one-on-one against
shaq mason and tom brady having to hold
the football it's a great way to take
away the underneath crossing routes at
new england likes it clutters the field
it also gives you a lot of disguise
ability with your coverages because
you've got eight bodies to play with
back there that's kind of the trend you
see in the NFL you line up five and you
either you can rush three four or five
but where teams are making it
complicated as if they rush three or
then they blitz out of that five-man
rush I will also get into quarterbacks
and you were talking with Andy binoy
absolutely check him out on the mm QB as
well as the ten things
mm QB podcast here's why I'm scratching
my head Andy we all agree that it's
difficult to evaluate quarterbacks
coming out of college that that part I
get and there's a lot of different
reasons for that what I find
mind-boggling is the disparity evidently
between guys like yourself and even some
other guys I've read recently Sean Fahey
and others about how good quarterbacks
are that are actually playing in the NFL
I saw where Sean had Carson Wentz ranked
as one of the worst quarterbacks in the
NFL he said he was bad last year bad yet
I read in your top 400 players that you
said if there were was one quarterback
that you could build a team around for
the next ten years it would be Wentz and
by the way Sean Fahey also had Cam
Newton number two it was a great piece
by him awesome stuff chock full
information those are the two that stood
out to me I guess my question is Andy
how can we even disagree this much on
how good quarterbacks are that we are
all watching it's a great question I
don't have a good answer for that I know
with when you get within the NFL and you
start talking to coaches the guys that
coach these guys and have to coach
against them the disagreements really
dissipate and a lot of people in the NFL
see these guys in similar life
now what you prefer in a quarterback
what traits are important to you that's
where you get some difference and that's
how you get into different schemes and
philosophies but like for example with
Cam Newton there is not a person in the
NFL that would argue anything other than
Cam Newton's not a precision accuracy
passer he's a power thrower but he's not
a pinpoint passer and that that really
shapes the discussion and so if somebody
doesn't seem Newton in that light it's
difficult to know how to continue with
the conversation because and if there's
no right or wrong necessarily but
coaches have to play against these guys
and their opinions are going to be
unadulterated because if they're wrong
on new and they're gonna lose the game
so it's you gotta find the common ground
somewhere and then try to figure out how
the conversation goes from there and I
think a lot of times it's difficult to
find the common ground or traits we get
confused about what quarterbacking
traits are important in the NFL coaches
prefer guys that can play on time and
from the pocket because everybody is so
good in the NFL that systems really
matter and whoever executes their system
the best that's who's going to have the
most success and almost every single
system relies on pocket passing because
it's the most efficient it's the most
stable it's easier to coach your other
ten guys around it so a lot of this
comes down to how we view pocket passers
and I think people outside of football
tend to put less of an emphasis on
pocket passing and the nuances of pocket
passing and they get more enamored with
highlight plays or big plays or or what
have you running around which has its
place but it's not how coaches view
quarterbacking you got the Patriots win
in the Super Bowl I saw in your story I
guess that maybe it's a two-part
question it would be does Julian Edelman
injury affect that and if not the
Patriots then who
yeah sorry look I learned the hard way a
few years ago Edelman is an important
player because I used to think well he's
a product of the system he's an
underneath shifty guy he's just cold
Beasley who happens to play with Tom
Brady but when he was out of the lineup
in past years that offense functions
differently and negatively and he also
has been used as a lot more than just a
slot receiver lately so I'll be the
first to say Edelman is an important
player having said that they have other
guys who can do similar things Danny
Amendola if he can stay healthy that's a
big if but he can do similar things as
Edelman just enough they do such a great
job with their formation in that that a
lot of the times it's if the receiver
executes basic stuff well the system's
going to get him open anyway so I think
they can survive that one if it's not
the Patriots to me Pittsburgh's the most
dangerous team and they might even be
the most talented team in the AFC they
have unbelievable number of weapons on
offense and that defense Ross in the
second half the last season that was one
of the five best defenses in the NFL for
just taking November and December that's
a young fast unit they run a complex
game they dialed the scheme back last
year everybody got comfortable and as
the season went on they put more of the
scheme back in we're gonna see a
continuation of that this year that's
gonna be a tough team to deal with all
right Andy last question with the guys
here and I are having a month draft
starting next hour what is the best
month of the year oh I'm a big I like
the holiday time of year I listen to
Christmas music when I watch film and
have the tree on next to the TV so I
will I guess I'll have to say a holiday
season in December and then I'd work
back November October September it's all
in football months I know that Wow
December so who we only have ten picks
so what would be the two that would get
left out in your mind but two months the
worst to my head in order to boy
February's tough you do get the Super
Bowl
February but you get the pressure of
Valentine's Day and that that you know
that it's a double-edged sword I'd
probably say February can go out and
June what happens in June I mean what
goes on it does June even have a holiday
and moons the start of summer I don't I
don't like that a February I can deal
with you know that's the kind of
analysis that we brought you on for by
the way Andy I appreciate the time thank
you so much yeah you got it thanks for
us the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings
on audience